Speaker 1: In the midst of just a packed weekend
of news involving Russia, Ukraine and the
possibility of a Biden Putin summit and so
many other things, it almost got lost that
a judge has determined Donald Trump and his
children will have to answer questions under
oath as part of an investigation.
This is a massive, massive story.
A New York judge shot down a bid to block
the state attorney general's subpoenas of
the former President Donald Trump Jr. and
Ivanka Trump.
But this is a massive, massive story.
A judge ordered former President Donald Trump
and two of his children Thursday to answer
questions under oath about the Trump Organization's
business practices in the state attorney general's
civil probe against the company.
Remember, this is a civil probe civil not,
not criminal.
Lawyers for Trump, Trump Jr. and Ivanka wanted
to quash the subpoenas from Letitia James,
his office, arguing the investigation is politically
motivated and designed to provide fuel for
an ongoing criminal probe into the company
by the Manhattan District Attorney's Office.
In his ruling, State Supreme Court Justice
Arthur and Andersen gave the green light for
the three to be deposed within the next three
weeks.
He also ordered the former president to turn
over documents and information subpoenaed
within two weeks and portrayed the Trump's
claim of being selectively targeted as overblown.
The Trump lawyers indicated at a hearing that
they would appeal if anger on let the depositions
proceed, quote There is a likelihood that
we will appeal, said Allen.
Future Force, the attorney for Trump's kids.
What could happen if they ultimately do testify
is something called taking the fifth.
Taking the fifth.
The Associated Press reporting the choice
could soon be Trump's in a New York probe
to plead the fifth or not.
That is the question Donald Trump may face.
Trump's lawyers are almost certain to appeal
the decision.
Barring a successful legal challenge, Trump
would face a decision between answering questions
under oath or remaining silent and invoking
his Fifth Amendment right, a tactic he has
equated with evidence of guilt.
Remember that?
Remember Trump's previous statements about
people who plead the fifth?
Just a reminder
Speaker 2: Fifth Amendment bar the mob takes
of.
If you're innocent, why are you taking the
Fifth Amendment?
Horrible, horrible.
The mob takes effect.
If you're innocent, why are you taking the
Fifth Amendment?
Speaker 1: Wow, that's a that's a fair point.
And Donald Trump speaking about it regularly
during the campaign,
Speaker 2: her staffers taking the Fifth Amendment.
How about that?
Hmm.
And her ringleaders getting immunity is down.
She has people taking the Fifth Amendment,
four people, plus the guy who illegally did
the server.
You know, he put it in the illegal server,
right?
So they have five people taking the Fifth
Amendment like you see on the mob, right?
Right.
The mob takes it.
If you're innocent, why are you taking the
Fifth Amendment?
Speaker 1: That is a beautiful question.
Now we all know what Trump's going to say.
If he ends up taking the fifth, he will say,
No, no, no.
Listen, those people were being legitimately
looked at because they did things that were
wrong and they took the fifth.
So they're using the fifth is evidence of
their guilt.
But for me, these are unfair, politically
motivated witch hunts.
So it's totally different.
My analysis of people pleading the fifth and
making you look guilty.
That's only the case.
If you're not me, if you're me, it's all politically
motivated and blah blah blah.
This is genuinely a problem for the Trump
family, and I think again, I want to restate
this is all related to a civil case, not a
criminal case.
But it is important in that it could set precedent
as to whether Trump could similarly be forced
to and or answer questions under oath in a
criminal case.
And we know that there are multiple investigations
looking into whether Donald Trump has committed
crimes, not just civil infractions or has
civil liability.
So we're obviously going to be following this
really closely, not the news that Trump was
hoping for, and this sent Trump into full
panic mode, and we're
going
to look at his statement next.